[Musique]
ça y est mes amis du centre val de loire
le street art a envahi la ville de
bourges grâce à nathalie une passionnée
de tous les arts qui va donner rendez
vous possible aux portes du very vous
m'expliquez l'action du collectif urban
halles qui rhabille les quartiers à
travers l'art pictural
celui nathalie bonjour à toi alors tu as
choisi roumain vendons que le canada
pour commencer notre parcours tu fais
bien de parler de parcours les
curiosités du van donc dans le quartier
du val d'auron c'est un parcours ludique
d'art urbain pour faire entrer les
habitants dans les différents recoins du
quartier quels sont les objectifs du
collectif urban al la rencontre contre
citoyen peut mouvoir l'art contemporain
va tu as tout dit c'est déjà ça c'est
donc comment c'est venu tout seul crée
le lien dans le délire grave il y en a
qui font de la déco intérieure dans la
maison moi c'est dans une ville et puis
là on rencontre des habitants et je me
rappelle très bien caldea c'est martin
qui nous a prêté son échafaudage vorace
et moi aussi j'ai des travaux chez moi
la maison est ce que quelques brèves
vous prêtez l'échafaudage aussi la
semaine prochaine les gens du quartier
c'est ce qui motive quand tu te
réveilles pour le faire en sorte qu'ils
se rencontrent exactement comme on a
fait une oeuvre sur le lac on nous a
prêté un bateau un bateau c'est martine
mercier pour le bateau s'ils volent un
bateau contacter martine
c'est le groupe qui me montrer donc il
sait à ses néons
nettoyez elodie l'éducatrice de rue
bonjour la vie c'est tout vous aimez
vous l'artiste pouvait placer ses
pochoirs les jeunes remplissent à la
bombe pour nous c'est important que les
jeunes et puissent se sentir bien dans
leur quartier se l'approprier qu'est ce
que cela vous a fait de rencontrer les
artistes street art comme ça d'aller
voir le faire seul et d'apprécier quoi
vous voulez vous y mettre nous allons
bientôt et on va faire un tube des
généraux ce choc des générations est ce
que vous l'avez déjà vu cela et bien non
pas celle ci la mission est réussie
grâce à vous et vous allez faire croire
aux enchères concernent sancya nesat a
fait de la papauté à vous jeter quoi du
coup alors décroissante tous les temps
tout le temps même du rapt on n'est pas
très doué
l'oratoire dédicace à la papauté que je
voudrais chanter un jour à la papauté xi
en plus
du groupe dans la foulée tricoter ce qui
prouve être une banale c'est un éventail
artistique très large là on n'est sûr de
rien on being cette action a permis de
montrer aux gens qu'ils étaient aussi
entourée d'arbres tout cas ça fait son
effet dont bravo à un banal et surtout
bravo à martin donc si vous n'êtes
échafaudage un bateau au delà même
martin au 06 35 18 35 35 18 et les
chiffres ont trop mais c'est parce que
les polonais
tués mais c'est quoi la suite au bénin a
longtemps bénéficié sous le porche on a
fait un joli graphisme toujours
[Musique]
le voilà le tunnel de monde vous voyez
là les noms des jeunes qui ont participé
à cet atelier
en fait l'idée c'était de refaire ce
porche parce qu'ils avaient été
vandalisés les jeunes qui ont participé
ont pu recevoir de l'argent de poche ses
marques et au coeur au royaume uni un
artiste parisien a repris la devise de
jacques coeur donc qui a son palais en
plein centre-ville dont vous avez un
mini le street art au centre ville
debout avec le mur de bourges c'est un
mur que l'on recouvre tous les deux mois
et bien mesdames merci beaucoup merci
pour ce parcours et sur cet ovale de ski
tarte et je me borne mélo mais non mais
pas avec le vélo
difficile appliquée
[Musique]
merci à toi